- Un décor de carte postale.
Et les ténors du gouvernement
Trudeau pour accueillir
le chancelier allemand.
Le Canada déroule
le tapis rouge.
JUSTIN TRUDEAU,
premier ministre du Canada
- Réellement une opportunité
pour le Canada et l'Allemagne
d'approfondir leur amitié.
- Visite officielle sur fond de
crise énergétique en Allemagne.
Alors que la Russie ferme
partiellement le robinet du gaz,
Justindededeau se présente
en allié. Les deux leaders
se préparent à signer un accord
d'exportation d'hydrogène vert
destiné à l'Allemagne.
"Le Canada va jouer un rôle
important dans le développement
des énergies renoublblbles",
dit le chancelier allemand.
Justin Trudeau promet aussi
d'être au rendez-vous
pour livrer du gaz naturel
à l'Aagagagne. Il évoque avec
prudence la possible renaissance
de projets de terminaux gaziers
sur la côte est du Canada.
JUSTIN TRUDEAU,
ieieier ministre du Canada
- Ces compagnies sont en train
d'explorer maintenant
si le nouveau contexte, les
nouveaux besoins de l'Allemagne
et de l'Europe changent la donne
suffisamment pour aller
de l'avant avec ces projets.
- Une visite assombrie
par les critiques de l'Ukraine.
Kiev reproche au Canada l'envoi
de turbines en Allemagne
pour alimenter le gazoduc russe
Nord Stream 1. Ottawa n'aurait
pas dû contourner ses propres
sanctions, disent les
représentants de la comm
ukrainienne au Canada.
MICHAEL SHWEC, prés., section Qc
du Congrès ukrainien caenenen
- On demande d'arrêter
toutes affaires, d'isoler
complètement la Russie
sur le plan économique.
- Le choix esttititifié,
maintient le premier ministre.
Selon lui, il ne faut pas
donner un prétexte au président
russe pour couper davantage
l'alimtitition en gaz
à l'Allemagne.
- Nous n'allons pas le
laisser continuer d'utiliser
la politique énergétiquecococom.
- "On ne doit pas laisser
la Russie diviser les alliés",
dit le chancelier...
...qui n'a pas manqué
de remercier le Cana
pour l'envoi des turbines.
FRÉDÉRIC MÉRAND, CÉRIUM,
prof. de science politique, UdeM
- Le Canada est déchiré entre
sa solidarit l l l'endroit
de deux partenaires.
- À l'approche d'un hiver
difficile, où la facture de gaz
sera salée pour les ménages
alndndnds, le chancelier cherche
l'équilibre entre sanctions
contre la Russie et pression sur
le portefeuille des citoyens.
- La crainte à Berlin, c'estde n
de l'opinion publique s'il n'y a
pas des mesures en place
qui permette de préserver
l'approvisionnement
énergétique de l'Allemagne.
- Justin Trudeau n'a pas
de solution immédi
pour combler les besoins
énergétiques de l'Allemagne.
Le Canada veut contribuer
à la transition pour réduire
la dépene e e de l'Europe
envers l'énergie russe, mais
l'effort prendra des années.
Ici Louis Blouin,
Radio-Canada, Ottaw